hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're going to talk
about in this video is when you're
working with the half-angle formulas how
do you know if it's positive or negative
you've probably seen the formulas in
your class or in your textbook and
you're wondering you know what's this
plus or minus doing here you know how do
I know if it's positive or negative or
is it both right so we're going to clear
that up in this video so in this example
we want to find out what's the sine of 5
PI over 8 well we know our unit circle
and we know the different values on
there like the 30-60-90 in multiple of
those angles or pi over 6 PI over 4 PI
over 3 etc but PI over 8 is not one that
we know okay it's not one that we've
memorized on the unit circle but we
recognize that 5 PI over 8 is actually
half of 5 PI over 4 5 PI over 4 is one
that we know can our unit circle it's
right there ok and when you look at this
point right here we know that the sine
and the third quadrant is negative okay
but 5 PI over 8 this is 5/8 PI 5/8 pi is
going to put you right about over here
ok in the second quadrant now in the
second quadrant sine is actually
positive so we're interested in where 5
PI over 8 is not where 5 PI over 4 is so
we're going to look at 5 PI over 8 our
actual angle and we know that sine is
positive so we're going to use the
positive quantity ok so does that clear
it up it's not the angle that you're
going to be using 5 PI over 4 so let's
see if we can simplify this a little bit
further so this basically comes out to
sine of 5 PI over 4 divided by 2
ok it's 5 PI over 8 so this is our X
this is what's going to be going into
our formula here in place of x equals
square root of 1 minus the cosine of 5
PI over 4 all divided by 2 and we're
taking the positive quantity because we
know 5 PI over 8 is positive here in the
second quadrant 5 PI over 4 though is
negative square root 2 over 2 okay / to
the 2 negatives are going to cancel and
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to multiply
the numerator and denominator by two to
clear this complex fraction so if I
distribute the 2 I get 2 plus square
root of 2 because these twos are going
to cancel in the denominator here over
for the square root of 4 though it's 2
so I'm just going to write this as the
square root of 2 plus square root of 2
all divided by 2 this 2 is no longer
underneath the square root because we
took the square root of 4 and that's
your final answer and this is positive
so I hope that cleared up any confusion
about you know whether it's positive or
negative just look at where the angle is
that you're actually trying to find the
sine or the cosine of find out which
quadrant that's in for a second third or
fourth don't worry about this angle here
okay and then just remember you know
when you're in the first quadrant its
positive positive negative positive
negative negative positive negative and
you can see that you know the sine is
the y-coordinate so if you look at these
Y values you can see if they're positive
negative it and the cosine is the x
value you can see if those are positive
or negative and then that will determine
the sine so subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and I
look forward to helping your math in the
future ones I'll talk to you soon